anyway you know what i'm saying yeah
glad it i'm glad it comes well the guy
that i dated
last before him was just big burly
athlete yeah and i when i met him i was
like why
i couldn't explain why i was really
attracted to him also i remember your
friends and family were going what the
[ __ ]
my my family wasn't like that they
weren't there was only one friend that
did that
yeah who was that and she was my ugliest
friend yeah yeah
so she i think she was just projecting
oh okay i don't think that it came
from anywhere beyond her own
insecurities about herself um okay
um what did you guys fight most about
i don't remember fighting with you we
don't fight no fighting right
i i because i think the v was the video
games a problem
here can i say this though yeah can i
say something yeah like
yes but i i was also here's the thing it
was two bobby's like i
that's the other thing too like we were
so similar
like he would play video games but i i'd
be like bye he
like i wouldn't and it takes somebody
like you to be in a relationship with
bobby to
kind of show up in that way to be like
hey
like i don't want to be roommates yeah
but
numdum like me like was just kind of
i just kind of rotated around it like it
was
i did the same thing but in my own way i
kind of wish i had more of that
more like going kind of like feelings
about it because like
i look at him i'm like [ __ ] you gotta
get up like move your toes or something
because that's all he does it's like
he'll sit
for 16. did i did i sleep in a lot back
then
bobby yes you well at the time
at the other i don't know if you still
have them but you had the blackout
window
he still did yeah uh-huh yeah that's
right yeah yeah
well yeah you would i mean you would
sleep till like six
nothing has changed nothing has changed
nothing has changed yeah
so i mean that's i mean so i could sit
here and like
yeah i mean you play video games uh do
you still eat bags of sunflower seeds
yes every week i have to empty out just
jars and jars of seeds
yeah sunflower did i have a glue thing
back then yes you glue your hand
have you you have not changed at all
[Laughter]
did he have did he have fungus feet back
then
i don't know i don't think he did no no
because after her is when i really
started hitting the um spas
did i go to spas back then yeah yeah all
the time you remember you had that big
white head is it remember oh yeah yeah
they had the spot for like three days
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then you go yeah yeah i was like
where have you been
saying that yeah yeah oh god yeah
because remember i told you about the
hot and cold today yeah
i keep telling him so for years he's
using this [ __ ] same
um pimple ointment from the 80s he
doesn't think
he doesn't think there are new ones that
have been developed that work better
yeah yeah so we were at the desert over
the weekend he was like i can't go to
sleep this pimple hurts too much i was
like here have some of this
yeah and i thought that was resistant he
was like no only this one works i was
like uh
yeah yeah only person gel that's a
[ __ ] yeah yeah from
[ __ ] rite aid yeah i mean and then
she goes she gives me this
expensive i i blotted it on it was just
gone
it was just amazing they have new stuff
yeah what's it called
let's promote it oh it's called um
circumference that's the conference
really good stack
yeah yeah that's my new thing uh all
right so you have any more questions
um hang on do i do i do i i think i do
did i watch porn back then so much
was it on um dvds at that time yeah uh
maybe
yeah yeah maybe because he would it was
so weird because like for as messy as he
is like he had his porn collection
really like categorized yeah
it was like full on that like you tried
to stop
like you were gonna you and uh your what
was his name
harley charlie
chase crazy charlie they were gonna
stop masturbating you remember
everybody knows yeah what the [ __ ] yeah
we're gonna stop masturbating and going
to like
porn hubs and i don't know what they're
but you were just gonna stop watching
porn yeah yeah and
remember and that's we talked about on
your show that's when you got
your red tattoo because you had to go do
something
that's right remember that that was like
day negative one that you guys stopped
doing
that's right so you got tattoos yeah hey
guys we're going to take a really quick
break to share some of our favorite
sponsors with you